I want to talk about what's happening in
Ukraine though and as you can see the
Ukrainian ambassador to the UK is with
us now van impristico hi lots to talk
about we appreciate you taking the time
to join us
um let's start with the fact that you
were there at Christmas time what's it
like
that's not easy I have to tell you that
I came first of all I drove myself
through the whole Europe and I saw that
how you know everybody is preparing for
the Christmas and somebody went through
the Christmas already and Ukraine was
dark and when I came to the home of my
mom she's with us now but I use the
apartment there were no electricity for
two days
so everything is cold and dark and quite
quite gloomy but people somehow adopted
to this way of living
what is the
um emotion overriding emotion in Kiev at
the moment in kivas is is better but we
also want to to Nikolai which is south
of the Ukraine next to just liberated
Harrison and there is much much much
tougher because the bombardments are not
stopping and even the governor was
showing us the place around the place
and he showed us the city council which
is not happen now because it's been
bombed out and people even the council
itself has to find the place somewhere
to have the meetings and do their
business
the blackouts are continuing power not
available for long stretches
um however the Russians think that the
bomb bombing of your infrastructure has
not been as successful as it should have
been I hope they understand that this is
just not working something how people
proved that this is not the way they can
deal with us and in most of the cases
your nation itself proved it that boom
bombarding the population you can have
the softening of the position of the
government
talk to me about what is happening
um in solidar
this is important Place buys not huge
it's not it's not Victory or a huge loss
but this is important and sorry that in
Ukraine means actually is giving up the
salt so that's the famous for the salt
mines and all of this and Logistics we
are fighting for that and Russians are
throwing
hundreds and hundreds of lives into the
salidary and near in Bahamut we will see
how it will go but they I understand
they're trying to present to the leader
at least something that they managed to
acquire at least something of importance
okay I'm just being advised by my
producer Andrew apparently the latest um
wires copy suggesting that the Ukrainian
Deputy defense minister is saying that a
fierce battle is continuing on the
solidar front we are holding on that
doesn't sound that positive does it
there is not much of solidar left in the
first place and it was totally destroyed
this is a teeny tiny it's not even town
it's just something between Village and
town and the the question is how many of
Ukrainian lives we have to you know
spare if we leave the solidar and we
will concentrate on the Bahamut or
something else but this is very
localized it's not it's not a big deal
what is a big deal is for example south
of Ukraine where our efforts are
concentrated as well
we believe that two British voluntary
Aid workers are missing
um they were last seen on Friday
um heading for solidar
um suggestions that one of them has died
do you know anything more about that we
know something about it and we're
sharing with your security organizations
we were successful in withdrawal and
your people from Ukraine before
we still hope that we'll be able to do
it this time as well
dee can you confirm that one of them has
died I'm sorry okay not on TV okay
um you have sort of dismissed what's
happening in solidar huge salt mine um
something between a village and a town
the Russians see it um somewhat
differently they see it as further
encroaching into your territory this war
is almost a year old where is it going
you're right I'm not the dismissive each
and every small town each and every
square meter of Ukraine territory is
important what we were saying for quite
a long that we need something which will
allow us to you know to to get out of
this gridlock we can't be a smaller
Russian Red Army trying to defeat bigger
Red Army we have to be much more
advanced in that we need technology
intelligence and training something will
start to receive the training was good
here you remember that even here in this
island way
trained 10 000 people since the
beginning of this year we'll have
another 20 000 trained by your people
but also other nations and Equipment you
know this this conversation this
discussion about the tanks for example
this is what is needed right now because
we have to get through these fields long
long steps and in east of Ukraine
um suggestions from our defense
secretary that it will be a dozen
Challenger tanks Challenger tanks
hopefully more
that's the point that I was going to
make because I was just speaking to the
um head of former head of our army he
was not where you are and he was saying
you need 50 or more
we need thousands that's for sure
because Russians are putting thousands
of tanks in front of our lines we have
many of ours but we need something
better then we can come up right now
with the old Soviet style not that bad
but still outdated so the challengers
the Abrams the leopards which are in
abundance in Europe this is the way to
go
the the leopard ones um they are the
license for that I believe is German so
they have to give Authority for that to
happen where are you with that do you
know this is the beauty of situation
with you you don't that's your tanks you
can give them at any moment that's how
our conversation is going if anybody if
everybody who have the tanks like the
poles where yesterday promised to give
the tanks of their parts to Ukraine they
still have to give the permission from
from the Germans and we are we are
working with them separately you know
this you've probably seen the discussion
the Germans are saying we won't be doing
it alone but when Nations asking can we
have your tanks been transferred to
Ukraine there is no distinctive yes so
here or United States or in some other
nations which produce their own tanks
like like French for example much easier
and French already gave some light tanks
the will tanks when NATO countries start
to give you military hardware on that
level does that ratchet up
the situation
I believe it's a bit too late to talk
about the crossing some red lines
there's so many of them being already
crossed and the sickest one was
Ukrainian border between Russia and
Ukraine so let's leave it also already
too late we have to do whatever we can
to you know to reduce the suffering on
both sides and just finish up the work
um we are being told that President
Putin is open to talks on the crisis in
Ukraine is Ukraine open to talks with
President we will open before he started
the war but what we're told that we are
not discussing anything when he is in
our territory killing our people the
best thing is to get of our territory
and we start negotiation how we live
together next to each other for four
million years to go
includes removing
um Russian troops and Personnel from
Crimea we made it clear they occupied
our land everything is occupied of ours
should be restored to our sovereignty
this is a basic and that's Crimea as
well as well 2014 dating back that far
that Russia has changed its military
commander chief of the general staff um
garasimov is uh now head of the Russia
or his head of the Russian military is
now the military commander as well what
difference will that make to the war I
believe this is maybe that's the last
step the next one the Putin himself will
have to command his troops because
that's the success they're showing and I
understand that this the last change you
know how can he explain that it is
allegedly second biggest army fighting
with ukrainians who did they lost and
they were talking that they will take
over the key in two days and all of this
stuff now he begging for ceasefire he
has appointed his his top leader
military leader in the command of of
iteration which he called limited
military operations not in the war
but
you know is a pretty impressive military
commander does this look potentially as
though Putin is now doubling down
she is impressive military commander I
don't believe that he was commanding
troops for decades he is good
strategists if if Putin is sending his
best strategies to to command the troops
on the ground it means that he is quite
desperate we are not dismissive we
understand the danger of Russian Russian
army we understand the danger of this
hundreds of thousand people being
mobilized it's not like you know World
viewers all of them we understand if
they will have another mobilization as
it will be very difficult to deal with
them so we are careful but at the same
time we're quite optimistic they're
throwing everything they have the last
Pieces Just to secure the victory which
we don't allow them how worried are you
about what's happening with a gunfire
and the armored vehicles up on the
Belarusian border
because Russians that this is the
problem with escalation with Bill
Russians if they're preparing for what
they're doing allowing more and more
Russian troops and their territory
sooner or later this situation will come
to the point when somebody will make a
mistake or this mistake will be
investigated so what we're trying to
tell Bill Russians that will be tragedy
not for your regime if you if you allow
this word to be engaged completely you
know what would they do and they
allowing Russians to bombard us from
that territory will come from a hotel
but not by their Truth by Russian troops
but you're concerned by that we're
concerned we have to keep our forces on
north of Ukraine you know withdrawing
them from the front lines just to be
sure that they're not coming and not
trying to cut this line which allows us
to you know to be connected to you guys
to West what more support do you need
from the British people
been generous already and you know all
did all the money or the all the
generators allowing ukrainians to be to
to fill the the worms the food
everything been done and support to your
own government
in doing what has been done through this
very difficult economic time for you as
well when the standard and that's what
is appreciated
the world focused on what's happening in
your country
we believe that we are showing that this
case is right you know Nations promised
us to give up if we give up nuclear
weapons will be protected and this is
very important for the whole Nations not
just work somewhere inside Europe it is
for the whole nation for the hope of the
whole globe if anybody will talk to Iran
I don't know North Korea they will have
to know that the West will hold this
side of the world if Ukraine was
promised to be protected that should be
done you must be concerned though that
um interest will Wane and also the cost
of living crisis right around the world
will impact on the support that the
Ukrainian people in the Ukrainian
government can expect
we believe that we have to finish up
this war and it's difficult to go
through it we will have to all of us
will have to you know pay the fair share
most nations are paying the fair share
for the future that's what we are trying
to present it's not about us maybe maybe
Russians will will finally understand
that that's not the way to live and
maybe they will have better better
government later on so this investment
in the future if you wish
the anniversary of the war is coming up
next month who would have thought this
time last year that you would have found
yourself in this position if ending the
war
next month or next year depends on
Crimea what will your president do I
believe that this moment the president
will do what he promised so many times
you know this bit too late to discuss
and actually Russians never asked us to
Crime here they even in early 90s they
try to you know to grab some land some
say artificial to create some artificial
Island in Black Sea
they never offer offered us to you know
to talk about the territories which were
given to Russian Federation from
Ukrainian territory in the same time of
reforming the administrative borders in
Soviet Union so this is purely
theoretical thing now this principal
matter of the territorial sovereignty
how much longer do your people have a
stomach for the fight
we are fighting so far and who could
believe that we will fight a year and I
have to tell you from my own
observations in Ukraine the nation is
very much militarized which is not very
good but at the time of of War everybody
is sort of working towards the victory
before I let you go just give us an idea
for um an average Ukrainian person what
a day looks like
let's do differently let's you come to
Ukraine and see and tell your own people
how the life of ukrainians look like
what about that and it's not sounds like
a very good idea okay we'll do that
thank you very much for joining us thank
you